maria will you come up to our digital
space i'd be honored to i would be your
little subject and i could get a
piercing yeah okay
and how many piercings will you have now
what number are we at i have eight
uh when i was six years old steven
spielberg not to be a name dropper
i swear i'm not being a name dropper
he
said i had to wait until i was 10 years
old to get my ears pierced and if i did
that he
would get them pierced with me
and
i didn't really have that kind of like
certainly i you know my dad wasn't
around so i really looked at him like a
father and i was excited but i was also
so happy to have like a man set a
boundary with me not that i understood
it that way at the time but i i agreed
and so i waited and i did i got my ears
pierced when i was 10
um on my 10th birthday i was so excited
i mean like when i would walk into his
office wearing lipstick he'd be like
please take that off
and i was always like okay
like that's how parents are supposed to
you know function they're supposed to
make you feel like you need to be age
appropriate and my mom and i just didn't
live like that we lived like friends
not parents so
my daughters
they have asked me to get their ears
pierced since as long as they could
speak but i said you know what i'm going
to follow steven spielberg's advice and
you're going to have to wait till you're
10. if if it's okay with you if i may
i would love to bring them to you
i would love that it would be great such
a full circle moment for me because like
like the first parenting i ever had like
was him saying like no you have to wait
if i
could wait anybody can wait
my mom and i were struggling a lot for
money and um there was a bunch of
endorsement deals that came our way
after e.t
and he said don't take them because
you'll
just be as you know you'll
you'll water yourself down and you'll
sort of
sell out too quickly and you could be
more of a flash in the pan and if you
really would like to have
a long career and you would like to keep
going
you have to be very careful about your
choices and you have to be thoughtful
and it was such good advice and i
totally got it when i was seven and i
said okay
then let's not do anything let's wait
and
my mom listened to him too and we just
kept doing movies and making our living
that way because there was so many like
commercials that came our way after e.t
all these brands and companies and my
mom and i were really struggling so it
was very tempting
but
we just
thought
do what stephen does he knows what he's
talking about and he
i knew he had my best
interest which wasn't
what i felt about everybody
i trusted him more than anybody else
and honestly not until i was in
my
late
20s did i sign on to be a cover girl it
was like really the first major
endorsement deal like literally my whole
life was like no to everything
because of his advice and he was right
is there any other like life advice that
you've gotten that really sticks out
like that
when i did my playboy
he had his whole heart department cover
me up in the magazine and he sent me a
large quilt that said cover up
and he like turned me into like this
1950s more wholesome woman but he never
made me feel bad he always had a
sweetness and a humor about it there was
always love with everything he did
but he wanted me
to
be a good girl
you know
ironically e.t said be good
and then i wasn't a good girl for a long
time you know and then i had daughters
and i felt like i learned so much about
what was important or appropriate
and
it shocks me now that i would ever be
someone who would do playboy or like
dance on david letterman's desk i like
don't even feel attached to that person
it feels like a memory but i'm so glad
that i did all those things because i
think it's what made me
seek out being appropriate and safe it's
like i lived life in reverse maybe too i
think i had like a midlife crisis at 13.
but
it's fun raising girls now knowing all
that i do
because i'm like oh i've learned a lot
of things
and it is so fun was there something
that surprised you when you became a
parent that you weren't expecting i was
surprised that you could still
not be ashamed of your past
embrace it
and not pretend to be someone else or
think that you shouldn't have done those
things
that they could be a part of what builds
you as a character
and a human and that you don't have to
have regret
or shame
or
denial that you can take all of that as
like tools in your arsenal to carry with
you into your present and future
and that really surprised me because
i thought god what if
what if my kids find out you know things
about my past and i just thought
i can't wait to share my whole journey
with them
and
i'm glad they have me who is so
convicted about them being kids and
stable and appropriate and all these
things that weren't exactly my journey
and i don't parent them the way i parent
myself because i think i did have shame
in how i parented myself
how could i let myself you know become
so wild or
fall into drugs or
lose my career at 13 or
get locked up in an institution
you know
have relationships too young i mean
there were so many things that like
brought on so much shame
i felt like i had to apologize to
everyone but then i also felt like
really liberated
i was like well guess what
i'm not perfect good i don't have to
pretend to be
i'm still rebellious i'm getting my ears
pierced right now you know
my kids know that like i swear and i'm
not perfect and i'm not trying to
pretend to be some like laced up person
and deny my past and i sinned and you
will have a different life i'm like no
no i really learned a lot of things
here's what i learned you're gonna
figure out what works for you but this
is how i'm gonna parent you
because i can see a lack of parenting
doesn't you know isn't ideal but it's
it's been a lot of learning
i really didn't want to screw up as a
parent
but you do you make mistakes and there
are such learning curves i think shame
is something that we can collect in our
lives but how we deal with it
is
kind of the art of life
and i'm wondering like you were talking
about like why i got so deep and dark
and weird no i love it do you have like
one specific thing that you look at at
this point and say that could be my
legacy or this could be the takeaway
from everything i've done
i mean work wise i would say that like
ever after taught me the most
because it just we as girls are told
that cinderella who is kind which is a
very very important
trait for us to embody
but
it
also taught us to wait to be rescued
and that movie
and that story taught me that i could
rescue myself
that you that one should rescue
themselves and still get love and the
prince if you want and all that good
stuff but
don't wait
don't wait to be rescued rescue yourself
first and then you can go
find anything and do everything and
anything that was very liberating for me
as like a young woman
definitely freed me up from old cliches
that might have held me back in my life
i know that people
want to feel safe
whether you're a kid or you're an adult
you want to feel safe
now my kids are first can i keep them
safe can i make them feel safe and then
how can i do that with each and every
person that i encounter i was put on
this planet to raise two girls
talk about second chances
i could have been
such a disaster in my own life but i got
to
thrive and survive into the luxury and
fortune and privilege of being a parent
to two girls everything must have
happened for a reason then everything
made sense this was all
hunting and gathering information for
them okay
cool
and you know all they're gonna say when
i get home is give me i want mom
what'd you think
oh
my
i just couldn't love it more
you